I love the idea you proposed to try and
get money back into the market which is
you said look we should give everyone a
thousand bucks every two weeks use it or
lose it it like disappears if you don't
spend it within 14 days and I gotta say
that would be one way to get us to spend
all that money and I'd love the idea
like did like because it would force us
to to actually not save because right
now I think you were the one who pointed
out we're saving more money than we ever
have
it's 48 14.4% savings rate and
increasing the most it's been in more
than 40 years and so if everybody's
saving money then nobody's spending it
and you know this all comes down to
confidence and ruin you know people
aren't going to spend money unless
they're confident that they're gonna be
able to either get a job or keep a job
you know there's just so much
uncertainty and the oh we're past the
point now of just giving people the
money we've got to get to a point now
where we've got to have people spending
money and get that multiplier effect and
what I suggested was that we did a
little bit to do a little bit different
than the stimulus checks the twelve
hundred dollars that we give because
people saved a lot of that where they
could but the one place that we missed
in that $1,200 college kids
you know they weren't eligible for that
for those but yeah all their money
college kids right because they have
everything they've got to spend I mean
and and they're not savers and so in
what I proposed was starting with
college kids and effectively the same
eligibility otherwise for their $1200
you would get a debit card and that and
they having a debit card debit card goes
to your point we have no way to give
funding to people right now we saw what
happened with the $1200 where tens of
millions of people had to wait for a
check and some were still waiting so as
a country we need to have an ability to
direct deposit to every citizen right
because if and when this happens again
that problem needs to be cured in
advance but I digress but with my what I
was proposing is a debit card we're
effectively $1,000 every two weeks for
two months and you have to spend it in
ten days doesn't matter what you spend
it on but you have to spend it will tell
retailers you can't get cash back in
when someone used to be this debit card
and then let him go out there and spend
where they make if it's rent if it's
food whatever I love it man we should
call it the Cuban card and then the most
popular man in in the country